[Music]
twitch
is a platform built on gaming
doris
dory but it's home to more
much more boom oh that's
now remember she wanted it crisp
[Music]
yeah give it a try dude it's got little
and now the biggest streamer on twitch
isn't known
primarily for playing video games at all
although he does
sometimes try who was the killer
hassan [ __ ] also known by his channel
named hasanabi
has changed twitch forever because in
2020 the streamer with the most subs
is political no there is no tolerance to
the intolerant mother
if you expected me to be one of these
like i need to do civility
oh no like if you thought i was gonna be
one of those people
well guess what i'm not [ __ ] i'm here
to make fun of republicans dude all day
every goddamn day and politics isn't a
side effect of some other career
it's the main draw it's why hundreds of
thousands of people
tuned in to watch him on election night
we are going to find out
who's gonna be the president who who out
of the two
geriatric [ __ ] is going to lead this
country
to our inevitable demise and whether you
agree with his own political views
or not it sure looks like the future of
twitch
isn't just about games real americans
don't celebrate losers pack your bags
bucko
you lost it's also about government
[Music]
hassan [ __ ] was born in the state of
new jersey
but spent much of his childhood in
istanbul the capital of turkey
even so as he told the h3 podcast
he was obsessed with the country where
he was born
i i read english books when i was
growing up i was like i was a weeb
for america okay i was an america boo
like that's part of the reason why it
was so easy for me to assimilate to the
culture here
in the past 10 years that i've been here
11 years that i've been here now
because i was just always obsessed with
american culture
hassan returned to the united states and
attended miami university
before transferring to rutgers and
eventually graduating come lauda with a
dual major
in political science and communications
and while he was still there
he interned at his uncle jenk yuger's
workplace
the young turks what's going on guys
this is a bitsy
or bts or behind the scenes with the
song hiker aka
woke bay the youtube show was known for
progressive news and opinions
but when hassan started there he wasn't
in front of the camera
eventually though he convinced them to
let him try his hand
at hosting his own segment as part of
tyt's
the breakdown the format was simple
hassan got in front of the camera
and talked about his views on political
issues but it eventually became a bit
more adversarial with hassan criticizing
popular figures
on the right better watch out tanya you
got fired in a blaze of
shame from the last place after pulling
the same [ __ ] uh-oh have i already
offended you
you gotta admire someone who builds an
entire career around getting
offended and then going hold on hold on
i gotta go record this it's like you've
built this reactionary riff-raff style
character and now you're just stuck with
the shtick and before you know it you're
gonna be looking like you're
kellyanne conway at the age of 35 and
your career will still be rehashing old
racist conservative tropes
and as he confronted issues he was
getting noticed
earning the moniker woke bay
coming down the carpet is somebody that
instagram goes crazy over his name
is woke bay first of all uh thank you
for
uh appreciating the latest fits i've
been throwing out on instagram because
every time people make fun of me i'm
like i got the queer eye approval [ __ ]
the other thing i was gonna call you was
a progressive is that offensive
i don't know i don't really mind it
obviously i am a bro he's a turkish god
okay somebody clipped me hassan i want
to be your friend you know
do you hear that is really cute okay so
i guess my first would be hassan
hassan spent several years with the
young turks but his own personal
popularity was growing
he was a progressive public figure but
unlike many of the other hosts and
contributors on tyt
he was young and relatively unfiltered
some weird reason in america it's so
much easier to regulate women's choice
than it is to regulate guns
i'm like looking around to see if i've
jerked off to anyone
and i i really haven't except for you
actually
i have seen i i've seen one of your
porns
in hindsight it's unsurprising that
hassan would end up taking his talents
to twitch
but at first he mostly just played video
games
and honestly his takes were sometimes
more compelling
than the gameplay oh [ __ ]
oh no what the [ __ ]
do you choose what about the difference
in opinion boys
what about the difference in your
opinion boys
[ __ ] in early 2018 when hassan made the
jump
many other content creators were already
deep diving into political content
chief among them was steven destiny
bonnell
a starcraft pro turned twitch
personality
so i'm destiny and i try to make sure
that when we talk about breaking news
we're not rattling off some dumbass
[ __ ] that we have no family we're
talking about that's what i'm what
destiny what is this i'm nina and i go
through nice life not being a white
piece of [ __ ] nice to meet you destiny
don't ever [ __ ] address me like that
again
when i got into debating like two years
ago my goal was just to like explore
those arguments because it's really fun
for me
and i saw that online there were a lot
of people that claimed to have good
arguments
that were making very bad arguments and
the first time they talked
things between hassan and destiny
started off
pretty well for those of you who are on
my side
of the stream destiny is awesome a
couple of the it was like some of my
moderators including space and also
some of the fans like ragbang were
telling me that i should link up with
this guy
and then i started watching his videos
and they're they're excellent
i really like what he's about so i'm
excited and i hope you guys get to know
him a little bit better and you can
enjoy his videos as well
although it didn't stay that way for
long
can you not answer this question i said
in certain contexts it could be okay
what do you mean by a certain context
not like you're reading it out of a
dictionary but in the context of an
offensive line i wasn't gonna do this
but like
um i didn't really read the logs that
got leaked or whatever but i have seen
you say the n-word on the internet
before
in the context that you use the n-word
when you're calling someone an r-worded
uh little f worded n word that is not an
in and that is not
a problem okay so it makes you look
like a terrible person what about a male
that's significantly smaller to me yeah
i already
i already mentioned that i wouldn't hur
i wouldn't hit a person who was
significantly
if destiny attacked me
if destiny attacked me no gun just like
straight up physical altercation he
tried to attack me i probably wouldn't
hit him back
and thankfully that relationship as
dysfunctional as it might be
gave us one of the best hassan moments
i'm not going to talk to a black person
like trihex and say
hey the n-word it's always
you think black people what a [ __ ]
liar dude what a [ __ ]
weasley little liar dude what a [ __ ]
weasley little liar dude holy [ __ ] dude
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude literally
lying still lying to his audience can
someone at least bring enlightened
destiny that he's literally lying to his
audience
but that first destiny debate and
everything that followed
was part of hassan's ascent he might
have started with fortnite but
the politics streams were setting him
apart
even so he was still working at the
young turks
and even launched a new series in august
2019.
what's going on ladies and gentlemen
it's me hassan
[ __ ] the prodigal son this is my show
called agit prop short for agitated
propaganda
as hassan's popularity continued to grow
he began to routinely face opposition
just for being a political figure
and in august 2019 he did something
that brought him even further criticism
america deserved 9 11 dude
i'm saying it we're there to partner
with them we're not there doing our own
thing we're there partnering and
training in a video game
and i'm i can't do this i can't do this
guy
has the understanding of foreign policy
of like a 12 year old
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this dude didn't he go to war and
like literally lose his eye because some
mujahideen a brave [ __ ] soldier his
eye hole
with their dick uh well wow he was
triggered wasn't he
i mean that is the definition of a
leftist getting
triggered and man that is exactly the
outrage culture that we have right now
he is a
perfect example of it you know he's
trying to walk his comments back
now and good on him for trying to do
that i know that i was
i know that i was inappropriate i
understand that which is precisely why i
took action immediately as soon as i
realized like oh
this is going to be misconstrued i don't
want this to be weaponized
i don't want this to be uh i don't want
this to offend people
if you watch the entire video i go dude
i'm saying it
yeah and then i i'm like how is anything
i'm saying controversial
we literally armed the same groups and
and
caused destabilization in the region and
then were shocked when the very same
people that we armed
gave weapons to gave training to turned
around and hit us back like how is that
in any way remotely controversial
hassan was banned from twitch for a week
as a result of his comments
but he continued to stream after serving
the band
in fact in january 2020 he decided to
cut ties with the young turks
and fully commit to streaming and it was
maybe the best move he'd ever made
just keep running straight
[Music]
[Music]
baseball is a [ __ ] sport i'm glad it's
getting worse stoppages
[ __ ] you since assange started streaming
the united states had experienced
political turmoil
but it really kicked into high gear in
an election year
i'm not going to lose my mind if donald
trump wins
especially when i've been ringing the
alarm bells for months
i will not be happy until joe biden is
sworn in or whoever the democrat is is
sworn in
[ __ ] dude trump
orange you orange dictator
you [ __ ] cheeto you're [ __ ]
finished dude
as the coven 19 pandemic kept many
indoors
they sought out streaming entertainment
in greater numbers
in the span of two years a political
commentator
had not only made the move to twitch but
he'd now become one of the platform's
fastest rising stars and he was
beginning to rub
elbows with some of the most popular
names in the gaming space
check this out check this out come
closer
okay this feels weird wait now watch me
oh
dude holy ah don't hurt me dude
am i done now i can play with miss give
right hello
discord what's going on guys i i just
want to warn you i've only played one
game
so far and like i've already gotten
scouted by
faze and hundred thieves i'm kind of
good
dude i'm just impressed you know what
those two things are i thought you just
knew
democrats and republicans
but more than playing with other huge
streamers
the election and the surge in demand for
political content
gave him opportunities what
oh my god everyone blast this tweet
please okay that's crazy that's crazy
that's crazy that's we have to make this
happen we have to make this happen
but that would be incredible that'd be
awesome and so in october 2020
alexandria ocasio-cortez and ilhan omar
played among us with some of the biggest
names in progressive political content
on twitch and youtube and foremost among
them
was hassan you know big shout out to
hassan because he was
just a huge you know he helped really
wrangle all of this together
oh no oh
no this is terrible ten seconds to vote
okay i'm gonna vote oh god i'm voting
ilhan but i don't know
oh no i think it was ohan
the way she was like where were you
we're about to find out if i threw him
off
oh my god
while aoc's stream also her first
was the biggest it was a huge
cross-pollination that
undoubtedly helped new followers find
hassan
and then on election night hassan had
his biggest stream
ever a peak of 230 000 viewers
watched him as he sorted through the
election results
i'd be yelling about all this [ __ ]
regardless whether or not you guys were
in here or not
i would be just yelling into a literally
dark room
be yelling it at 35 people
if no one else was watching but um you
know i just wanted to express my
gratitude and
i know things look tough right now
but um we still got each other
it was a far cry from his first stream
where
just a handful of viewers watched him
play fortnite
but since then hassan has grown to
become the most sub-two streamer
on the platform and he's been using that
position
for good joining another aoc stream
that also featured canadian member of
parliament jugmeet singh
which raised two hundred thousand
dollars to fight housing
and food insecurity i feel good go go
myth on this one
oh i don't think it's him though it was
just a joke
it was true yeah
i can't believe they just i can't
believe they just needed him oh my god
jug meat is too good
whether you agree with his political
opinions or not
hassan has shown that there's an
appetite for
more on twitch and he rode that wave to
the very
top of the platform oh look at me
i'm from denmark we have free
hospitalization and corona checks at
every hospital
thank you huh [ __ ] you man i'm [ __ ]
dying out here trying to get medicare
for all past
god damn it dude with more potential
political uncertainty ahead
it's likely that twitch will have to
carefully grapple
with an even bigger influx of streamers
trying to make it
the hassan way offering contentious
opinions
on more than just the latest trending
games obama's talking about changing
systemic policy issues except saying
that accountability is worthless
did i just say accountability mother i
just criticized obama's
specific policy issue and gave you
actual policy
ideas that would be easy to [ __ ]
implement
you [ __ ] dog [ __ ] neo-liberal [ __ ]
and as for hassan's opponents well until
a challenger emerges
they're just gonna have to learn to live
with them um well i'm a
political commentator so i normally talk
about politics but
sometimes i have a variety of incels
that come into the stream so i give them
advice every now and then that you guys
can give them as well like girl advice
you're an insult i'm an insult myself so
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages